so dr. Peterson you talk about this idea
of ending unnecessary suffering and this
idea of committing one's life to that at
a minimum I mean that's the obvious
thing that you could do a lot of
students I think accept that premise and
view what they're doing as trying to
eliminate or reduce unnecessary
suffering and they see activism or other
forms of direct service as fulfilling
that goal do you simply disagree with
like the content of what they think the
tactic that they are using to end
unnecessary suffering or do you think
that their motives or their intentions
are not even the same as yours oh it's
too public you know there's this there's
this old saying from the from the New
Testament about not praying in public
hmm right and the idea is that if you're
going to commune for the higher good you
should do it private because otherwise
you're warping your ethic in some sense
by demonstrating how virtuous you
virtuous you are to the world it's like
you know I'm you go out there with a
stick and a sign on it that says I'm
against poverty it's like yeah no
kidding so it's it's it's it's an
abdication of responsibility with the
mask of social virtue and you want to
solve difficult problems you figure out
how to get along with your brother the
one you've been fighting with for five
years or see if you can staple your
family back together see if you can stop
fighting with your girlfriend and have a
relationship that lasts for more than
two weeks you know it's like there are
things that you should be doing in the
confines of your own life that are
private and humble that would whether it
would constitute genuine accomplishments
and those are the things that you should
attend to and no one's gonna come along
and say hey you know good job you're
your change in the world because it's
it's private but it's real and then
people don't do that and so no I don't I
don't trust the activists I don't trust
the activists ethos at all hmm
I think it I think everything about it
is is superficial and and trendy and and
too easy and and it externalizes the
blame the evil is always elsewhere which
is a dreadful mistake to make because
the evil isn't elsewhere
that's that's the thing that you
understand when you're wise is the evil
is not elsewhere it's you because you're
not everything you could be and so you
know you should work on that before
going and telling someone else that
maybe they're not who they should be hmm
so I think it's you know so I don't buy
it it's too easy it's far too easy and
it's too public and it's too self
congratulatory and then there's the
murderous like Marxist element which you
know I'm always often inclined to
mention so certainly I think you've
identified certain causes where the
public element or the
self-congratulatory
trying to do good could be harmful but
do you think there are cases for
instance I'm thinking of policy
influencing policy being a policy maker
it seems like something like that public
policy could be used to eliminate some
unnecessary suffering but would involve
a more public domain something where you
are trying to attract followers trying
to attract praise from other people look
look if you if you've established
yourself in the world as a credible
human being and people are asking you to
enter public service because of your
accomplishments then it's time to do it
right but before that it's a little on
the premature side and if you're just
setting your for self forward as an
avatar of an idiot of an ideology then
there's nothing to you except I think of
it as the chattering of various forms of
demons it's like you're not helpful and
if you if you look you want to think
okay are you fit to lead let's let's put
it that way okay first of all do you
know where you're going because that's
actually one of the hallmarks of a
leader leader knows where he's going and
maybe other people are also interested
in going that way but the leaders I've
met have carved themselves out a
personal vision right it's not some it's
not some cookie cutter ideological
solution to the ills of the planet
they've done a detailed analysis right
they know what they're talking about
and they're usually people well they've
had a successful relationship they've
had a successful family they have a
couple of degrees they've established a
business like they've made themselves
credible in five or six dimensions well
then maybe you know enough about the
world to dare to mess with its internal
mechanisms and if you if you don't have
that kind of in-depth knowledge
then you should just you shouldn't you
should no more work on the economic
systems of Western civilization then you
should try to adjust the electronic
systems of your automobile because the
latter is far less complex than the
former so of course there's utility and
policy formulation and in government
service and all of those sorts of things
but you have to you have to have
transformed yourself at least to some
degree into someone who's actually
competent before you should even dare to
do such things you think well I have
read some marks and now I know how to
change the world it's like that's a very
bad idea
yes the probability that you're gonna
take something complex that doesn't work
too badly and fix it with your idiotic
intervention is zero so well put
[Applause]